[Music]
agents it has been seven days since your
activation after the president invoked
national security presidential directive
51 and 19 days since this pandemic was
first recognized
if you are receiving this message you
have managed to negate the growing
violence and meet up with the other
members of your cell
in your designated safe house you'll
have noticed a number of shd gadgets
that you can utilize in your mission
but recently our friends on the research
and development team have gone one step
further
while the mobile communications network
is down across the country using the
division network they've managed to
bring us back online using your personal
device in something they call
resurgence
[Music]
resurgence is ubisoft's first mobile
entry into the division universe
but this isn't just a port of the
division one or two this is a fully
standalone game based within the same
universe as the base games
keeping true to its roots resurgence
will be an open world cover shooter a
looter shooter rpg and will contain both
pve and pvp elements
in essence this is the game we've been
playing for the last six years but with
a new story and available on your mobile
phone
the seating places the player as a first
wave agent who was activated in the
early days of the pandemic during the
events of the division one where a
devastating pandemic sweeps through new
york city on black friday and one by one
basic services begin to fail
within weeks society collapses into
chaos and the government activates the
division a classified unit of sleeper
agents
leading seemingly ordinary lives among
us division agents are trained to
operate independently of command when
all other means have failed
the division resurgence story is
completely canon running alongside the
timeline of existing events spanning all
the way through to the division two
this new addition to the story will
cater to both new and existing fans of
the franchise it is a standalone game
where no previous experience is required
we will see some familiar faces included
such as the rioters cleaners my personal
favorite rikers black tusk and a new
hostile faction called freeman
resurgence has both pve and pvp
activities
the large open world map has players
placed at the heart of manhattan new
york and there are campaign missions
dotted throughout that can be run solo
or co-op
here is a short clip of one of the
earlier missions where the player is
helping agent kelly fight through a
group of enemies in order to secure some
medical supplies
on target
clear
shot agent
clear
here's an elevator
look speed up
hope it works
i don't like that sound
cover me while i fix this
going down
not again cover me
here we go
god
keep them down
there enough mishaps
we should have been activated a week ago
i don't know why while they waited
stupid or incompetent
but i guess we get the leaders we
deserve right
guess you're wondering
maybe it's the system that's messed up
[Music]
trinity church isn't far let's move
however if you decide you'd rather
explore there are a number of open world
activities to stumble across which will
only take you around five minutes to
complete
in the division resurgence all campaign
missions side missions and open world
activities will be playable solo as well
as co-op
pvp which includes the dark zone and
other modes will be available at launch
but won't be present during the closed
alpha
the division resurgence is following its
routes by ensuring that deep rpg
elements will stay intact
there will be looting modding of weapons
crafting of items and other gear and of
course the ability to upgrade
as per all good luda shooters
it's about being able to build and grow
your character which best suits your
style of play
crafting works in a similar way to the
division 1 and 2 where players can
exchange looted materials for weapons
and gear
however it's not quite as
straightforward as that
for example each class of weapon has its
own crafting tree where new blueprints
can be unlocked
leveling up your crafting experience
will also increase your chances of
higher quality equipment being produced
with better base stats
mods offer similar bonuses to the other
games but with the additions of
attributes like toughness weapon damage
and a number of different types of skill
damage
this will mean that making the right
choice between mods will be more
important having a greater impact on
builds
with this in mind there is also another
layer to this where players can choose
between a number of different classes
they start out with each with their own
unique skills gadgets and signature
ultimate skill
each class also has a unique talent tree
which when upgraded can alter the
effectiveness of the gadgets and skills
available
while you're only able to choose one of
these to start with over time players
will be able to unlock others and there
are more to be released in future
seasons
being a mobile game the controls for
this sort of genre are a bit of a
talking point
however this seems to work quite nicely
when properly utilizing the in-game
cover system this could be manual or
automatic leaving it up to the player to
find the best configuration as well as
fully customizable control layout in
settings
the division resurgence is a
free-to-play mobile game
naturally this is a scary term for a lot
of gamers to hear as this often raises
the question so what are the micro
transactions going to be like
much like we've seen in the division 1
and 2 this doesn't mean we'll be seeing
pay to win elements being added nothing
will be locked behind paywalls and
everything that can be purchased will be
accessible and unlockable for free
purchasing options will only enable the
player to progress faster or unlock
certain cosmetics
however content called seasons will
continue to be pushed out every three to
four months with other events like
cosmetics and gameplay being released in
between
each season will contain a new main
mission a new class and manhunt as well
as a new battle pass exotic weapon
cosmetics game modes and even expansions
on the open world area
it really must be stated that everything
i've talked about here and have shown in
the video is being developed completely
separate from the studio working on the
division two they're continuing to work
on bringing new content to the game with
a lot more planned for the coming months
apart from the overarching story the
teams working on resurgence are from a
number of different studios that are
experts in mobile games doing their best
to bring tom clancy's the division to
handheld devices
using the unreal engine the intention is
to bring the aaa experience to mobile
this will be available on most high-end
phones but is still being optimized as
we speak to include as many devices as
possible
this is definitely an ambitious
undertaking i'm not a mobile gamer by
any means but the detail and sheer size
of the open world has had me pretty
excited about this addition to the
franchise for a while now
there has been a lot of focus on keeping
the transitions through the open world
as seamless as possible and this is
showing
my software development skills don't
overlap into the gaming industry all
that much but i can only imagine the
challenges around creating a game as
detailed as the division on mobile while
still making it playable to the majority
of users without needing a phone that's
less than a couple of months old
the addition of story elements that are
in the same universe as the original
games only furthers my excitement
what more will we see from before the
events of the division one regarding the
first wave
will there be story crossovers
or more importantly will my giant hands
and sausage fingers be able to play this
on a phone or should i just steal one of
my kids tablets or maybe i should just
get a touchscreen tv
anyway thank you very much for watching
if you have any questions let me know in
the comments i'll see what i can follow
up with soon cheers
i'm so glad to see you i just about
given up hope
hey i think i heard something
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]